databases not only allow easy access to
large amount of information
but also provide data for training
machine learning methods and for mining
genome-wide statistical
most of the databases of genetic
variations were created in the past
three decades in 1998
ncbi established the db snip as a
central repository of single nucleotide
variations
and other small genetic variations
identified in our species
in 2010 ncbi established dbvar to store
large-scale genomic variations
in 2012 the 1000 genome project released
the first batch of genome
and exam sequences of over one thousand
healthy individuals from all over the
world
on the other hand many databases have
been created for disease associated
genes and mutations
a good example is omim which is a
well-annotated database of human
diseases and associated genes
if you want to find the exact mutations
that are associated with diseases
the human gene mutation database hgmd
created in 1996 is a great choice
in 2007 lsdb the locus specific
databases
were created to organize mutations and
polymorphisms around each locus
two additional databases db dbgap and
clinvar
contain genes and variations discovered
by genome-wide association studies
or gwas and next-generation sequencing
to either cause diseases
or increase disease risks finally in
2004
cosmic database was created to contain
somatic mutations discovered in tumors
now let's look at some of these
databases in greater detail
dbsnp was created in september 1998 by
ncbi
the national center for biotechnology
information in the us
in collaboration with nhgri the national
human genome research institute
as a central repository dv snip contains
most of the human genetic variations
identified so far in both healthy
and sick individuals as this figure
shows
the amount of data of db snip has been
increasing rapidly over the years
each record in db snip contains lots of
useful information about the variation
for instance this record is about a
single nucleotide variation in the
homeostatic iron regulator gene
the ancestral allele is adenine which is
usually determined by comparison with
our closely related
primates a small part of human
population acquired varying thymine
the frequency of the minor allele
thymine is about 0.8 to 1 percent
you can click any panel on the left to
find additional useful information about
this variation
such as flanking sequences and minor
allele frequencies in different human
subpopulations
you can also find the clinical
significance of this variant
omimp or online mendelian inheritance in
man is a database of all human diseases
known to have a genetic component
and their casual or risk genes it was
initially created in 1966 by dr victor
mccoosick as a catalog of mendelian
traits and disorders in the form of a
book named mendelian inheritance in man
or men two book editions of mem were
published
as the data grows larger and larger and
the book grows thicker and thicker
an online version omim was created in
1985
and made publicly available two years
later
the purple bars in this figure show the
number of genetic disorders with known
molecular basis
the orange bars show a number of map
disorders caused by genetic mutations
omit now includes not only single gene
mendelian disorders
but also complex diseases with
susceptibility genes and some somatic
cell genetic diseases
there are two main types of records in
omim
the first type of records focused on
genetic disorders
for example this record of breast cancer
describes the clinical features
diagnosis and treatment of breast cancer
the inheritance model of different types
of breast cancers
the genes and mutations discovered so
far and other useful information such as
animal models
the second type of records focused on
genes that had been associated with
certain genetic diseases
for example this record on brca1 shows
its cytogenetic location
genomic coordinates gene structure gene
function
and evolution more importantly it shows
how brca1 was discovered to be
associated with several types of cancer
the families and patients studied and
the mutations that are identified
and the genotype phenotype correlations
omimp is a beautiful resource for gene
disease associations
[Music]